- [Chris] Late at night
I get inspired watching
all your stuff.
- Thank you so much.
Come on in, sit sit sit, yeah of course.
I'll take a coffee when you get a chance.
- Malibu yet?
- Uh, I think so.
Him and I are very friendly
but I don't remember.
- Yeah, that's my guy, man.
- He's such a good dude.
So what's going on in your world?
- The last years kinda bummer.
The director cleared with
them with the next five years.
We had two years left on my contract.
The whole field thing,
I just didn't see that going that well.
So I decided to leave and
then I started this thing
called Black Ops New Mellow with Kevin
and it blew up, you know?
We had Lebron and KD,
Russ, James, we had...
- Yeah, that's crazy.
- You know, it was awesome,
and then, you know,
after that happened, you
know, I watch your videos
and, you know I don't like the word,
but in a weird way I became an influencer.
So, all these companies start reaching out
- Offering stuff, offering money, yeah.
- Offering money, offering
equity, offering this,
and you know it was a
little overwhelming for us
'cause I'm used to being
a basketball coach.
Getting offered all these
deals, figuring it out,
and it's kind of keeping pushing.
And then during the
season, I have like 40 guys
that work with their
own retainer and try to
stay in this city, watch
film with the guys,
work with them, and then in the off season
comes with our season.
- I see.
And Kevin, what do you do?
- Yeah, so I've helped
him with the workouts
for four years now, I do
all the, basically just
the little things, the rebounding,
all the videos that are
shot around my cell phone,
all from the summer, all
the clips everybody saw
I just had around my phone.
- So you kinda do the stuff
that you used to do kinda thing?
Just like all leveling
up, like similar stuff?
- Yeah, well I think once
that, you know, it got bigger,
I mean the videos started
getting more popular.
We realized it was valuable,
so, and then I kinda
came on full time once we
- To make video, to
create awareness, I see.
- It was crazy man, we
started making these videos
and then the next thing
you know, the summer ended
and 880 million people
have seen the videos
just in one summer, that was crazy.
- 880 million views?
- It was views throughout
the course of the summer.
I don't know what a view
is if you watch the video
- But Kevin watched them all 15 times,
and he just acts as one person.
And who are you characters?
- They kinda, they help
us out with some brands
and kinda like a management thing,
- So you have a separate company you guys?
- Yeah, Disrupt Management.
- Disrupt Management.
- Jordan actually does some shopping
with some of your colleagues.
- Yeah I started selling
sneakers online in high school,
and that helped pay for school.
And a player on the Wizards
DM'ed me on Instagram
and I got him a shoe and then started,
he told another guy in the Wizards
and then I started DM'ing
people watching your content
DM'ing 20 guys a night, I
worked with a couple guys
on Vantage Sports getting them
clothing and stuff like that.
- Nice who?
- Cornelius, and I've spoken
to Jaylin plenty of times,
I think I'm meeting Keith in LA,
but you know, definitely just doing
self management now with Chris.
- Yeah, so I mean, I think
that if I have one question
for you, the toughest thing, you know,
because you take on so many clients,
so I have like 50, 60 NBA guys,
and at first you think it's a great thing,
the season starts, you know,
after every single game
you gotta talk to these guys
and then you gotta tell them,
you know, every problem they have,
it's on you, they put it on you.
And every time they have
a bad game, every time...
So, you know it's early in the season,
I got a little overwhelmed and I'm like,
I have 60 NBA players this, these guys
are like my girl friends,
that's really what it is,
you know?
So I kinda had to figure
out how to balance
living life and dealing
with certain people.
- Well, I think, you know,
anything that's not scalable,
like VaynerMedia, like I have
150 to 200 million dollars
worth of clients running
through the Vayner X machine,
but I don't deal with any of that
because I was okay with
building equity in other people.
- And then so, I mean, that's kinda what,
you know, we're at,
Kevin helps me with it.
One of the problems is that
these players are so delicate,
as you know, you know I'm sure,
so it's like they wanna talk to me,
it's like.
- Because you started by
starting with that was the equity
and if you started with us,
and if you started with us
and us, then that's all you have to do.
Derek Morgan and Braxton
Miller and all these guys
that switched over to
Vayner started with me,
but then I'm like oh, AJ's good,
and he's even more available than Gary
and fuck it all I want is to
work on my mid range jumper
and have somebody answer the fucking phone
every time on the spot, so,
I think what you need to do
is a couple things.
If you wanna keep building that business
and you view that as a
leverage to the other things,
which it is, nobody's fucking with you
like Black Ops had me coming through
and going three for 39 on the field.
You know, like, the key for
you is to figure out who else.
And really, really, and not be worried,
and the biggest thing that
a guy like you worries about
is he goes and does his own thing
and you just have to be okay with that.
- You right, that's the hardest.
- Of course, you have to, you
have to, that's how I feel.
I'm thrilled if Babbon wants
to go do this for Will Smith.
'Cause I know I'm great.
And that's all you have to do.
You have to be great at what
you do and be a good dude
and some people don't wanna be the guy.
I don't know him and I don't know Sally,
who's the third one that
you would decide to add
after this meeting.
Some will, some won't,
you know, some won't
just because they're like fuck it,
even though I kinda do, this is my guy
or they just like being number
two, three, four, five, six.
But you can't be crippled by,
because it's what happens.
You know, once he's got
the relationship with Russ,
LeBron, and Shlemron, well then,
he can just say I'm out.
But that can't stop you
from building a business
otherwise you're half pregnant.
- No, you're right, you're right.
And then...
- And then if you actually
have that vibe with him,
all of a sudden, like, you understand,
he'll go or the next guy will go,
or not go, period.
That's just a binary decision,
you'd almost be happy,
you know it's like being a coach.
Did you watch Bill and
Bill, the 30 for 30 yet?
- Yeah I did.
- You did?
Perfect.
Did you notice how fucking Bill Percells
was setting Bill Belichick
up to be a coach?
- Yeah.
- Good, and guess what,
him, or it's not him,
him, him, could be even
better at it than you.
And that's okay, you
just wanna be the tree.
- Exactly
- So that's it man, that's the game.
- Yeah, you're right.
- That's the game.
And you gotta start
putting energy against it.
Which means, those videos need to start,
you know, really putting people on.
Here's my thing, the thing
that you need to figure out is
do you wanna use the
training as a, like for me,
it's actually the world I'm living in now.
Like Vayner Media is actually not smart
in the same way that
you're training business
is not smart anymore, but
it's actually very smart.
Like, to me, I hate that I have an agency
and have to deal with all this shit,
but longterm, when I buy Pony,
and all the next generation
basketball players
are wearing Pony off the court,
it will all work out 'cause of this,
and I would've never been
able to do that by myself.
I would've been able to
make 25 million dollars
through your speaking and
writing books and being me,
and charging 100,000 dollars a day
to have three hour versions of this, cool,
but that's not 15 billion.
And so that's it, and
there's a lot of risks
and emotions and shit that
comes along with that,
when you're dealing with
people, CA was built.
Like, Willy Morris was built.
Like, people have done it.
By building out, you know,
other personalities, other
- What you're take on
watering down a brand?
I say that, so I have every sneaker brand,
every clothing brand in the world
wanting to do a deal, and I feel like,
yeah I have Mellow tell
me how you can't water it,
you weigh yourself down,
and at the same time
you wanna make some money
and it's toughed out
you know, if 100 brands
don't wanna do stuff
it's tough balancing out what
brand I wanna do stuff with.
- You mean you personally in your thing?
- Yeah, at this point, it's
gotten to aid me personally.
- I would, I would,
there's no right answer.
Like, here's what I know.
If Under Armour offered
you 10 million dollars
and you can't work with any
other brands, you do it.
- Yeah, nah, exactly, yeah.
- So, it's just an auction, right?
Like, if everybody's offering 100,
then you wanna take all 700s.
But if somebody's offering a million,
then you know, there's no right answer.
Here's what I'm saying, just never lie
and everything can work.
It's actually a great piece of advice.
It might not be fun to say
to KD something or Melo,
or Chris, it might not be fun,
but if you never lie,
you're in a great spot.
- That sounds great.
- You wanna eat, they know
that, you wanna do your job.
I would say this, it all starts and stops
with the thing that got you there.
Just 'cause I've gotten
bigger, I don't stop
interacting with people, I don't big time,
I wanna know people, like,
that will never go away
because that's what got me here.
So, what got you here is that you
were good at your craft
and guys trusted you.
- That's what it is is trust.
- And you don't wanna give that
up for five million dollars.
- You're right.
But you still wanna make money.
- And you should, which is
why the lying is the key.
Whatever you decide,
that's what you decided,
and whatever it is, it is.
I invested in Gowalla, which
was a Four Square competitor
when, five years ago when
all those Four Square
check in things happened,
I invested in Gowalla,
but told all my clients to use Four Square
because it was better.
That's why I sit here today.
It's very important.
You might get 15 million
dollars from Adidas,
you just better tell
them listen, if fucking
this classroom Duke that comes out
and three of them wanna work with me,
if one of them's fucking
ankle I think fits better
into a fucking Asics
shoe, I'm gonna tell them.
Like, fucking,
I guess El Mime probably brought
me those marbled panther,
like if I wanna rock those,
- You can do it.
- Then I can do it.
- You the man for that.
- And when I go to LA this weekend,
I wanna rock those, you
know, along with mine.
But that's because I told them look,
I'm still gonna come through
for you for what you want.
- Yeah.
I got another question for
you, what's your take on media?
So I've done, so you know,
this summer got done,
and I did GQ and Wall Street Journal,
and ESPN, I did everything
you can possibly think of.
And it keeps coming,
and now I'm at the point
where it's like I have
nothing else to tell you guys.
- Well you can tell the same
thing in a different place.
- So do you believe in
that, that I should keep
- Well I think it need to be strategic.
- The Rolling Stone is asking me
to do something I don't like.
Do I just keep doing every one of these?
Or do I stop?
- I mean, look, you do whatever you want
and I think attention is
the most important asset,
but I think you have to be smart, right?
Like, I'd rather you do something
with fucking Bar Stool than Rolling Stone.
Like go where the culture is.
- He's a Bar Stool fan.
- You know?
But, what's good about Rolling Stone
is that it gets you into new eyes
that don't see you on Instagram.
- See I have a clothing
brand that I started,
I started a clothing brand a
year ago called ColorBlind.
I literally made a hoodie, I didn't think
it was going to be much,
and next thing I know
it's Selena Gomez, it's the Kardashians,
everyone's wearing it, and...
- And when you say next thing I know,
talk me through that.
Because that's an important thing for me
to understand to give you advice.
- When that whole
- It wasn't like oh, I just
put this up shop went flying
- It went with all the Trump stuff
and police brutality shootings
and stuff was happening,
you know, I went to the
print store by myself
and I made a hoodie that said color blind.
So, it was as simple as that.
I posted it on my social media,
you know a bunch of guys
said yo what's that?
Mellow's like you need
put that on Chuckfide,
so I put it on Chuckfide, sells out.
- I love that Mellow's so smart.
- And, the next thing
I know, I'm struggling
because I have a team of two,
so I, we've done like eight
or nine different releases,
so that every release in
doing the fabric making,
so now it's like been going up, and
- Who runs it?
- Me, by myself, it's not (mumbled)
- Here's what I can say,
either you find young talent
that is so pumped to have
autonomy and run shit
and you keep 100 percent, and the trade is
you putting youngsters on,
they're gonna meet people,
they're learning, and then they can decide
what the fuck they wanna do at 28,
or you give up 20 to 50 percent to people
who know what the fuck they're doing
and you're not guessing.
You don't think they can do it,
they've been doing it for 14 years.
- What do you think about that?
- I think both work.
Supreme's cool.
You know what's more cool?
Nike.
Just depends what you think is cool.
- You right.
- Like Converse is more cool than Supreme
because they make more money.
You know, but for now.
What's great about cool
is you can get there.
You know, you're either
in control or you're not.
- And I agree completely
with what you say,
but when you're only
going for that big check,
I can't say no to that.
- I get it.
That's how people make real money, though.
Zuck's said no to a billion dollars.
You just gotta figure out
how long you wanna be in it.
It's not just about risk tolerance,
it's just more about do you know yourself?
Right?
Like, risk tolerance is
the right way to look at it
like on paper in a textbook,
it's actually different
than that.
It's actually like what
the fuck are you up to?
Here's what I know about you, without,
I don't know anything about you,
but here's what I know about you.
I think you'd really
struggle with the idea
of making 10 million, but
being known as a whore
and a sell out and
never being able to play
after four years from today.
- Yeah, that's my fear.
- Okay, well good.
Let's start with that.
I don't know what else to tell you.
I think the reason I am who I am
is because I leave so
much money on the table.
- It is tough when you're starting out,
the feeling when you get the
money from the elite players.
- I was 34 years old
when I left Wine Library,
I owned nothing.
How old are you?
- I'm 31.
- Perfect.
I was 34 when I left my dad's business,
I built it for him, I
owned zero percent of it,
which means the bank and the
world saw me as being worthless
I never paid myself more
than 70,000 dollars a year.
I was 34.
- That's crazy, man.
- I think you may overthink this moment,
and I think that may
lead to bad decisions.
- My fear is that in
selling, Russ, KD, Mellow,
you know, we kinda gave you this platform
and you're using us to sell out,
and that's my biggest fear.
- As you should be.
- It's about getting them better.
- And guess what, there's
some kid coming up
right behind you that is
thrilled to take 80 percent
of what you take to just do basketball
and work 10 times harder than you
because they don't have
all this other opportunity.
- That's what we're trying to do,
is make it so that we're gonna make money
off all these other deals
and these media things
where it's like, we're
known to have the best gym
and guys, these NBA and
college, how high school is,
they don't pay.
- I get it.
- That's the ultimate goal.
- Because of Melo and
his respect that he has
from all the young kids, everybody...
- I can really, really, really
help, and would, happily.
Through all these conversations,
I have real thoughts about this shit.
There's not an accident.
I'm gonna be the guy, and
it's based on the right way
of thinking about things.
And it starts with what
the fuck do you want?
'Cause I wanna buy the Jets,
I gotta do everything right.
If you wanna fucking smoke
weed in, you know, Jamaica
and bang hot chicks, well then
you can just sell out now.
'Cause that's easy.
And by the way, that sounds great, too.
Like, I'm not judging one's ambitions,
right now's the time you decide where
you want this thing to end
up and you work backwards.
- I know I want to be the most powerful
person in basketball.
- Well then you need to
really make it all about them.
'Cause they have the leverage, not you.
Period.
It's not even close.
- And I think just the
biggest battle, is, you know,
so right now I got the top high
school kids in the country,
top college kids, top NBA
guys, I got everybody.
And, you don't charge
high school kids, right.
You don't charge college kids.
So, you know, there's that dry period
that's not during the season that
- And you don't charge them because
you think they'll come with you?
- Once they get to the
league, then they can look,
that's kinda, they'll look out for you.
- Yeah but guess what,
you're building a brand.
Your old business model is different now.
You don't need to do as many pro bono.
Meaning you're so fucking
cool because of last summer
what happened on Instagram and YouTube
that you don't need that, they're just
gonna go with you anyway.
I would double down on
fucking LeBron and Melo
because that's why you'll get them,
not because you were nice to them.
- That's facts.
- I'm very aware.
- When you're around them and
you act like they're not there
they're like ahh, and then they
- It's even less about being cool,
like getting the girl to
come to you or the guy,
it's more about you do
it for LeBron and Russ,
like when they come out, like
sure Rick was nice to them
in high school and college, but now
that they're in the
league, they're gonna go
with the coolest brand.
This is recruiting.
You were the nicest coach,
you're the best friend,
you took care of their momma,
but I'm gonna go to Duke.
Brand always wins.
It's why Vayner Sports is gonna win.
- Yeah, you get it, you
guys have been winning.
- We haven't even started.
And we're already dangerous.
We have a guy in the green
room in our first year.
It's gonna be a problem.
- How many hours a night do you sleep?
- Six or seven.
I sleep, it's just that I
work so hard the other 18.
It's not about how much I sleep, you know.
'Cause you're not in the right spot yet.
The reason I'm good is
because I'm at peace.
- So what the problem is,
so that the games, right,
the games, I gotta break down
the games with the players.
- What time do you go to sleep?
Three?
- Well, yeah by the time
the player winds down
and wants to stop talking,
it's three or four AM.
- And what time do you get up?
- That depends on the day.
- You need to be smart, don't be stupid.
Change your world.
You're a guy that goes to
sleep at three or four.
It's okay if you start at 11.
I'm being dead fucking serious.
- You just feel like a
dickhead when you do that.
- Yeah, and then you just tell somebody
that's cool that you're judging me, dick,
but I went to sleep at four,
you went to sleep at 11.
I gotta get on this call.
- Yeah man, no, I appreciate
your taking us man.